monsieur benedetti merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france à leur
première question pourquoi les citoyens
en tout cas selon l'étude ne semble pas
avoir confiance en leur gouvernement
pour de multiples raisons d'abord ce
sont des pays dont les situations sont
différentes on plan d'abord des
fonctionnements des potes de l'état au
plan de systèmes sanitaires
mais ce que l'on constate ce qu'il y à
un fonds commun d'opinion qui considère
que les pouvoirs publics dans chacun de
ces pays n'ont pas géré de manière
optimale
cette pandémie alors il y avait
seulement un facteur que je qualifierais
presque de civilisation c'est que nous
avons aujourd'hui des opinions publiques
notamment dans les pays principalement
dans les pays occidentaux qui sont de
plus en plus soucieuses de leur propre
sécurité et qu'ils acceptent
vraisemblablement de moins en moins la
notion de risque d'eau qu'il y à aussi
si vous voulez ce sentiment collectif
qui aujourd'hui rend certainement
beaucoup plus difficile que par le passé
la gestion de ce type de situation par
les pouvoirs publics
le deuxième aspect c'est que quand on
regarde finalement l'ensemble des pays
concernés
il est clair que face à un phénomène
nouveau c'est à dire virus que l'on
connaît pas que les pouvoirs publics ont
pratiquement tous fait preuve d'une
absence de réactivité qui paye
aujourd'hui dans la perception l'opinion
j'ai parlé du cas français en plus
précisément est-ce que tout et son
contraire on n'a pas été dit pendant le
confinement est ce qu'avec ce virus ce
n'est pas un peu difficile de s'y
retrouver quand on est un simple citoyen
alors c'est vrai vous avez raison de des
assistés sur disons la stabilité de la
parole publique durant cette pandémie
on a eu
ça a été relevé par un nombre de
commentateurs et d'observateurs de
multiples injonctions contradictoires
qui ont été produites par les autorités
politiques et des otaries les autorités
sanitaires la question des masques en
étant me semble-t-il l'illustration la
plus incandescente puisque on nous a dit
en début de pandémie que le masque
n'était pas nécessaire puis ensuite
qu'il était est nécessaire et
aujourd'hui on le rend obligatoire dans
les lieux clos donc cette instabilité de
la parole publique n'a certainement pas
dix ont permis à l'opinion publique de
disposer d'une très grande confiance
dans l'action des pouvoirs publics
c'est à fait certainement extrêmement
extrêmement important mais il y a aussi
dit la réalité c'est que la parole
politique la parole publique la parole
de l'état était indexée sur les
incertitudes de la parole scientifique
et de la parole médical elle même donc
c'était certitude de la parole
scientifique cette incertitude de la
chorale médical qui est tout à fait
encore une fois compréhensible par
rapport à un virus que l'on ne connaît
pas à peser lourdement sur la
communication au public
alors justement il y aura peut-être une
deuxième vague en tout cas ça se
concrétise dans certaines régions au
niveau de la communication qu'est ce que
le gouvernement peut faire justement
pour arranger les choses qu'est ce qui
peut mieux faire aujourd'hui
alors d'abord si vous voulez je crois
qu'il faut pas considérer que la
communication est le sujet qui est le
sujet matricielle dans la gestion de la
crise le sujet matricielle dans la
gestion de la crise c'est la possibilité
de disposer de moyens qui vont permettre
de gérer cette crise et de disposer
d'une bonne capacité d'anticipation et
de réactivité
cela ça n'a rien à voir avec la
communication si vous ne disposez pas
d'une capacité de réactivité
d'anticipation plus des moyens
nécessaires pour gérer leurs
la crise c'est à dire les masques les
tests principalement et bien vous êtes
dans une situation où il est extrêmement
difficile de communiquer alors
aujourd'hui la situation a
considérablement changé par rapport à la
genèse de l'épidémie puisque nous
disposons de masques nous ne disposons
pas encore de capacités de test
manifestement insuffisante
mais dix ans les pouvoirs publics ont
les moyens en tout cas logistique de
pouvoir d'une certaine façon mieux
répondre à cette crise la difficulté là
encore c'est que ils ont tenu durant ces
dernières semaines et là je retrouve en
effet une question de communication des
discours qui était à la fois rassurant
pour permettre finalement le
déconfinement est aujourd'hui un
discours qui semble un peu plus
alarmistes au regard de l'évolution de
la circulation du virus
monsieur benedetti merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef revue politique
et parlementaire merci